hey y'all what's up
movie retrospective time going back to
2007 for this one
one of tom's favorite movies one of my
favorite movies i thought he yeah i was
like i was sure you'd be really excited
when this one won the poll
yeah one of my favorite movies this
movie here was a um
it's it's hannibal rising it's about
hannibal lecter
but it's a european flick and it's a
period piece and it's just
it's a classy horror movie it has many
elements
of almost like a superhero movie it's
it's a lot in some ways
it's a lot like batman begins yeah i was
reminded of that when because i've seen
this a couple times but when we were
watching it again for this review
i was like yeah that's what i was
reminded of and
lecter is young in this one and he's
shown
very much like a vampire
kind of very vampiric european
aristocracy
grew up in a damn castle ended up in a
dungeon
one thing leads to another he slowly
transforms into a
cross between batman and [ __ ] dracula
and a samurai yeah but uh that's pretty
crazy
real cool flick real good um
filmography good [ __ ] score
good acting um good story
they got a lot of the little details
right even down to the the period
fashion
and the military equipment and the tanks
because it starts off in world war ii
when hannibal was a little boy
just a good movie i like everything
about it you know what's interesting
though and
um so what happened with this one the
screenplay was written by thomas harris
who obviously wrote all the original uh
novels sounds little android dragon
uh hannibal all those but the thing
about it
so the novel came out in 2006. he did
not actually want to write
a prequel because he thought that i
guess he thought the hannibal lecter was
more interesting if he didn't know his
backstory
i think so i had read some of the books
i don't think i read the book of this
but um what ended up happening was that
he was like yeah i don't really want to
do a prequel but uh the production
company that owned the rights to the
hannibal lecter character
which was uh dino de laurentiis at the
time
he was basically well we're going to
make a movie like a prequel with you or
without you
so if you because we have the rights to
the character
so if you want to get in on this then
you better write the screenplay you got
to save this [ __ ] so
[ __ ] it up so he basically uh said okay
fine
and he really quickly like rushed out a
novel and then quickly rushed out a
screenplay that they based uh the movie
on
so uh it's weird because i kind of feel
like
this movie it didn't get great reviews
um the acting got good reviews like the
cinematography
got really good accolades and stuff but
a lot of people
thought it was maybe two um one it's
like you know you didn't really want to
know all that stuff about hannibal
electrics it was scarier if you didn't
um and also that it kind of seemed like
a little
in the same way that batman begins was
where it's just kind of a little
greatest hits type of thing where it's
just kind of like this is how he sort of
became a cannibal or whatever
i don't know i don't know if i agree
with that yeah don't listen to any of
that [ __ ]
no just watch the movie it's it's a good
movie
um they touch on a lot of motifs and
they touch on a lot of bases
um that kind of explain what could
happen
to a person who is trying to do the
right thing but they've been through a
lot of stuff
it's kind of like the creation of an
anti-hero that's exactly what this is
yeah because lecter is
starts off on a mission to avenge his
little sister's murder
and and trying to avenge what happened
to his family
but over time the inner conflicts and
everything because certain aspects
i can't spoil all the move i can't spoil
all the the plot
elements of the movie because there's a
lot of people that haven't seen this
and certain things can't happen in
certain
orders that end up forcing hannibal
to kind of become what he hates most he
becomes
kind of self-loathing in the very end
and it drives him over the edge
and that's when he becomes the hannibal
lecter that you know
uh it's a it was a process um
and he he he became the hannibal lecter
you know through
basically humiliation and abuse
and deprivation and suffering and his
reaction was to slowly
turn into something kind of like cross
between
kind of like batman and the punisher
and then at the end of this story
something happens to him
that ends up culminating in kind of like
him realizing that he is his own enemy
and that he
is what he hates and it drives him over
the edge and he
becomes just a full-fledged [ __ ]
cannibal
just out of this damn frustration and
self-hatred
and they kind of lay the groundworks for
that anyway
because he was a little kid during world
war
ii between right there
on on the eastern border you know on the
eastern front i think it was lithuania
wasn't it
right and his homeland is being fought
over between
a bunch of different factions one being
the soviet union those being nazis
and then local forces that were kind of
like paramilitary militia
who were trying to join up with the
nazis
but then they were also going rogue and
do whatever the hell they wanted to do
they were more like criminals than
anything else they were mercenaries
and his family gets in the crossfires of
all these big
forces that are you know far beyond what
a little kid could handle
you know he loses everything and um
he ends up being forced
later on through relatives
forced to kind of gravitate towards
becoming not a warrior for a
nation-state but a tribal warrior for
himself
and it kind of used samurai imagery for
that
because the samurai were kind of like
that they were roading until they got
they were like mercenaries they were
running until they
became a part of some kind of feudal
lord's army
or support network but other than that
they had their own authority samurai
could basically walk around and just
kill peasants
at will they had the power of life and
death over people
and they cut people's heads off and
showed them and
to get paid for the kills that they
scored in combat so all this stuff kind
of culminates into him
becoming kind of like a tribal warrior
for himself and his own family and um
things happen to show him how corrupt
human justice systems are and how the
poli
how the police couldn't save the
children during the damn nazi occupation
and that the vichy were [ __ ]
following nazi commands so were the
police but then after the whole war
they're
executing people for going along with
the nazis even though the police were
going to
go went along with the nazis so they
were executing
uh innocent people basically well people
that had done the same
horrible [ __ ] that they had done right
so he's seeing all well the guy that
they cut his head off he didn't give up
the children he gave up a dude
yeah who gave up the children and they
still killed him for [ __ ] giving up
the children when he didn't give up the
children
he just gave up another um
what was it he gave up another french
resistance guy wasn't he part of the
french resistance i think he was
yeah and they put it on a guy who was
fighting the nazis
instead of the dudes that went along
with it he was where were the police and
he goes yeah and you know
hannibal was like yeah you never did ask
you know yes inspector you never
answered his questions
where were the police when the nazis
took the children well the police were
sitting there watching it
so that you know so hannibal didn't
believe in
systematic justice you know not not
anything from a civilization he believed
in his own personal sense of justice
well it's kind of you were rude you were
an enemy and he would
give a deal with you yeah i mean you got
to be fair like everybody that
hannibal kills in this movie uh pretty
much had it coming
honestly i mean to be honest with you so
it's like yeah he's a serial killer and
like obviously we know how the character
goes later on like in silence and lambs
started though nobody's saying like he's
a good dude or anything but it's like
most like everybody he kills in this one
pretty much is like
they're pretty bad they're gangsters
they're terrible people they were they
were mercenaries in the war and then
after the war was over they kind of had
embedded themselves into organized crime
so he goes after a bunch of organized
criminals
for vengeance it doesn't have anything
to do with it well it's justice and
vengeance at the same time
it gets very confusing it's supposed to
be morally confusing
yes it drives him crazy yeah
because he loses everything and loses
the woman he loves behind all this
which that was weird too because it was
his aunt even though they weren't
related by blood yeah because she was a
widow she was a widow she was from japan
yeah so she was the one that gave him
this kind of like samurai influence he
he liked that he likes tribal warriors
more than
say you know law enforcement and [ __ ]
institutionalized soldiers and so he
wasn't into that
he's into self-development and totally
independent that's
because he didn't didn't trust authority
because he
when you see his upbringing you'd know
why well yeah i mean that's the thing he
actually
he seemed to have like a it was a nice
family they had their own castle or a
manor house or whatever
yeah he was uh he was an aristocrat yes
he was his
dad was a lord wasn't he yeah something
like that he had a castle
so i seen it kind of like dracula yeah
there is lecter castle which is kind of
like
castle dracula when you think about it
yeah yeah you can totally see like why
thomas harris wanted to give him that
kind of like origin story yeah and the
guy that's playing him as a young guy
and he does have a very vampiric
look even though physically he's kind of
ungainly looks a little bit like
frankenstein the way he stands but his
face is kind of vampiric
yeah that's a that's a french actor yeah
he was good in it i think
yeah i i liked him in it a lot actually
he doesn't really i mean he's not
anything like uh you know uh anthony
hopkins no
and the weird thing about it is that
even though
i guess i don't know because i feel like
other people have played um
you know hannibal lecter obviously other
than anthony hopkins even though he's
you know the the main one that everybody
knows but
it seems like most of the actors they
get to play were british but the
the guy that plays him in this is french
he doesn't say much
the character doesn't have a whole lot
of dialogue he has dialogue but
it's not as verbose as anthony hopkins
okay well he's kind of mute for a while
because of the trauma like when he's a
teenager and stuff grew up in captivity
basically
um yeah because after his family gets
killed and
you know i don't like i said i don't
know how much of this you want to spoil
because i feel like
you can i mean it came out in 2007 like
at the very beginning when he's a kid
like he's what maybe 10 11 something
like that yeah
um and his whole entire family gets
killed in this you know
in the crossfire in this battle or
whatever that takes place like by their
cottage yeah and then they so him and
his little sister misha who was like a
toddler
you may be four they had to run from the
castle and they were hiding in the
cottage
yeah and the castle got taken over yeah
by a bunch of
first the nazis took it over and then
later the soviets took it over and
turned it into an orphanage
and later on hector hannibal electra was
imprisoned in his own castle
because he turned into an orphanage and
you know and they were beating him up
and humiliating him in his own damn
castle
you know and um which that's got to hurt
a guy yeah
and uh what happened to his sister was
pretty hardcore too before all that when
he was still a little kid
some mercenaries bust in there and use
them for cover
uh because two armies were after him the
nazis were after him and the russians
were
after them and they couldn't go anywhere
so they had to hide in the cottage well
they started to starve to death so they
ate misha
yeah and uh so that's what all the
vengeance is about
and the cannibalism yeah yeah they ate
his sister so he was going to eat them
which i i can totally see that yeah um
yeah so
so basically this is basically straight
up like a almost like a samurai revenge
flick
because you know he has his little
sister is eaten
um and then he gets uh taken in
by i guess he gets saved he wanders out
in the snow and like the russian
soldiers uh
save him and then his cottage like you
said gets turned into an
orphanage and he gets stuck in there
because the entire family is dead
well it wasn't the cottage though it was
it was the castle yeah the cottage got
um abandoned yeah yeah but he goes back
to it later he goes back to it later
yeah that's right
so uh so yeah so he's in this orphanage
like i said it's not a great
uh situation he won't talk uh because of
the trauma
um you know even though he still they
say he still like yells his sister's
name in the night and he still like
dreams about it and everything yeah they
thought he was mute
yeah because he wouldn't talk at all but
then some of the other people say yeah
we heard him screaming at night so he's
not really mute
so at some point he says like [ __ ] this
orphanage thing because like i said
they're really horrible to him in there
so he escapes and then i think in the
book
um his uncle comes to pick him up from
the orphanage
um but in the movie his uncle's already
dead yeah so he actually travels to
france yeah he has to fight his way
across the
berlin wall to get to france too
yeah he crossed the berlin wall from the
from the back side they were shooting at
him but they didn't hit him
and then he gets to france and finds out
that his uncle's dead and it's a big-ass
french manor and then he's another
european aristocrat and his
widow is still alive her name was a lady
murasaki murasaki murasaki was her name
and she was a
japanese woman whose family got killed
in the damn hiroshima bombing
yeah she takes care of him and
a little romance kind of burst you know
kind of
happens between them she was more she
was more like his girlfriend and
then than any kind of mom yeah because
she didn't look that much older she
wasn't that much older
i mean you know it wasn't it was a
little weird but they're not like blood
related
no and her husband's dead right so yeah
it's a little strange but
yeah and he was like one of the only
survivors of her ex-husband's
family yeah so he deserved to be in
there he was family it was part of his
family estates you know just she took
care of him send him to university
yeah he goes to medical school yeah but
he also um
she also showed him all this samurai
armor that she had from her ancestral
because she was also like an aristocrat
japanese aristocrat
she had all kinds of samurai swords and
old samurai armor and
samurai puppets it looks like and up in
the attic
and he became and scrolls and stuff
showing beheadings and
attacks on damn certain castles that her
family was involved in so he got way
into that and he wanted to be a samurai
he liked that and that was part of his
and they do some foreshadowing he's
taking the samurai masks and putting
them on it looks just like the damn mask
from
the land yeah yeah the muzzle type bat
[Laughter]
and uh he was big into these bladed
weapons and that's and she trained him
in kendo
yeah he had some of these martial arts
skills when it came to blades
and then later on guns got involved it's
pretty neat it's very much kind of like
batman begins in certain ways it has it
really does remind me of that it has a
lot of that in it
and a lot of a lot of kind of
vampiric type overtones or undertones to
certain things
because he is kind of like a vampire
he's an aristocrat that kills people and
eats them or drinks blood it's about
like that
yeah and he's also like scary
intelligent yeah you know work around
real high class he's really educated
real intelligent
he can pass it down lie detector's test
because he has no emotional reactions to
anything
he's a psychopath yeah he can just you
know no emotions
because the first murder that he does
which is kind of like because like i
said he does one murder but then he kind
of i guess he kind of gets a taste for
it
and then he's like well i gotta find out
uh you know who the dudes were that ate
my sister
and so the rest of the movie is him just
basically tracking them down because he
didn't know their names
he could only remember he remembered
their faces yeah because he saw them in
his dreams so he like drew these really
elaborate pictures of them
you can remember what they look like
yeah he couldn't remember what they
called each other though
yeah so he was trying to but remember he
stole the um
that uh the truth serum stuff so he
started
hitting himself up with sodium to make
him remember about trying to have
visions
and stuff you know and he did remember
he
remembered well no he he remembered
their faces he didn't remember their
names until he found the dog tags
yeah because it so happened that like
during the early uh
attack like after his sister got eaten
and everything like that the
there was something that came it's like
it knocked the house over
and they dropped the bag that had like
all their dog tags in it so it was still
there
yeah and all their jewels and id and
everything they were stealing from you
yeah
yeah and he found he remembered their
names by the with the dog tags and he
remembered what they called each other
by the dog tags and then he started like
trashing
down one by one yeah and doing all these
kind of like elaborate
uh sort of traps you know like for them
to fall into
um and they do kind of get the better of
him in the end but it's like
so the first dude that he kills was
actually not one it was not a revenge
thing
really like it wasn't with the first
dude because the first duty kills is
that butcher
it was kind of like revenge but not
originally she and he insulted uh
lady murasaki yeah while they were out
shopping he was like making some racist
slurs about
her [ __ ] yeah he didn't like that so he
tracked him down fishing and killed him
and um so like i said he's he he brought
his
he brought his head to lady murphy he
left it in there like that
left it in front of the samurai armor
like she had shown him in the pictures
that the samurais but dude she was oh
they will say that this is murder
you know but she helped cover it up even
though the dude did kind of deserve it
yeah he was just he was an [ __ ]
he was also xv she they had a whole
bunch of uh
a whole bunch of enemies because he had
been giving up jews to the nazis
yeah remember so so everybody he kills
in this is a piece of [ __ ] they're all
bad guys
yeah and um
the french justice system was not
bringing these guys the right gut people
to justice they showed that
they were killing [ __ ] french
resistance people you know
one aspect of this movie i liked though
is that the one cop
uh who's playing i can't remember the
character's name but yeah there you go
uh played by good played by dominic west
yeah he was a good character because
he was a cop and he suspected that
uh hannibal had been had killed a couple
of the dudes because like i said they're
finding like severed heads and why not
yeah and uh he suspected it but he
couldn't prove it but then basically
he's like look i kind of
imply that i knew that you did that yeah
just don't kill anybody in france or
you're gonna get arrested
he's like but if you do find him bring
him to me and i'll take care of him yeah
because he's like i want to get him too
well he was trying to
he knew he he's like you know basically
he's like
i know that you do you did this to
[ __ ] avenge you know
what they did with what she said to or
what he said to
lady murasaki and i know that these
other guys that they're all bad
and he's like but what's going to happen
if they kill you they'll go free
yeah okay who's going to go after him
because i'm the only one that can go
after him just tell me what you know
and i'll i'll go after him you know and
then you can go along your way so he
wasn't going to press charges on him he
couldn't really prove it anyway
yeah but he knew what i mean he pretty
much knew that he knew though
and he also was like telling his friends
he's like
i don't know what you call that but he
he needs help basically
you know the medical science doesn't
have an explanation for that dude
yeah there's basically like he's kind of
like a monster yeah he says he's some
kind of a monster now he says what what
that boy
he says that boy lithuania died as is
out in world war ii what this is this
isn't quite it this is something else
because you know this was happening i
think in the very early 50s that's when
that part
supposedly happened maybe mid 50s and
um they had not identified what a serial
killer was but popeel knew it was some
something odd i mean they did have [ __ ]
like that happen but they didn't really
have a concept it wasn't codified yet
not everywhere right you'd have to write
read the right book and it would have
been some experimental [ __ ] at that time
but he he knew that that that was some
kind of a monster
and he did that because he didn't have
any reactions to anything you could put
him on a damn lie detector and ask him
all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ] up and he
was just he wouldn't be stressed
out cucumber because he had been through
all that [ __ ]
and he didn't really have kind of a
self-preservation instinct he wasn't
afraid of anything
you know because he his he had
emotionally been maxed out long time ago
so you know being questioned by the
police was nothing to him
lying was nothing to him or just evading
he just thought it was funny
to evade questioning and flip it back
around on somebody
because you know he had a [ __ ] i
guess you could say a very expanded
[ __ ] overton window nothing upset him
and he just said that it was monstrous
yeah because you know he'd play with
other people's lives and deaths and
wouldn't be like nothing
you know although as i said he in this
movie in particular
um he doesn't really kill anybody that
doesn't have it common
well he feels it's justified yeah and
you know he doesn't think the criminal
justice system can handle it because it
was demonstrated in the story that the
criminal justice system went after the
wrong people
yeah so he because he was already an
aristocrat
and he was intelligent he figured he was
the ultimate authority
yeah so that's interesting that that you
bring that up because it is kind of like
that's maybe why they made him like an
aristocrat
of course just because he would have
that an inbuilt like sense of
entitlement exactly
an in-built sense of superiority right
he's like these are just peasants
with their [ __ ] thing i'm [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] dracula
that's what dracula was dracula had his
own castle was an old war hero from
hundreds of years ago
he had a whole tribe of damned gypsies
that would fight to the death for him
and everything he was an authority
figure he was the authority
yeah and he could and he was the undead
who's going to tell him what to do
he's a [ __ ] vampire no one can tell
the undead what to do you're going to
listen to your food
a little chicken's going to tell you
pasta you're a chicken
you know chicken and fish and little
cows are going to tell you what to do
now you're [ __ ] food
that's right a lot of people don't look
at it that way that's what
dracula was he was the authority yeah
okay
he wasn't a criminal he was the [ __ ]
lord yeah
yeah and you definitely i mean there are
really a lot of
uh a lot of parallels yeah uh in this
story
with a kind of a dracula origin story
yeah so i can see wow
i mean even though you know like i said
thomas harris kind of like wrote this
really quickly because he hadn't
actually planned on writing another
novel about hannibal lecter and he
especially didn't want to do a prequel
so he did actually write this one really
quick but now that you mention it
um you know maybe he just was bouncing
it off the wall of dracula and he's like
well i'm just gonna give him like a
dracula-esque
uh backstory that's what's that's what
that character would need
yeah gravitas and moral
self-justification
of course i have the power of life and
death over everybody i'm a [ __ ]
you know elector i mean my family
existed before the republic it's that
kind of [ __ ]
it's that kind of thinking this old
school
authority i would be back from the
[ __ ]
back from monarchy yeah you know that's
what they're talking about i would be
interested to see
because i think when i first heard that
they were going to do a prequel
i w i thought that they were going to do
something about
um dr lecter's like early
uh like psychiatric practice which i
think that would be interesting too
like just that aspect because this this
story is basically like him as a little
kid
and then him is like a late teenager
he's probably like 18 or 19 he's
supposed to be
right because they show him as a little
kid and then it's eight years later yeah
when he's in medical school but the
story
ends with him in canada so that's when
he got to the united states and that's
when the practice
yeah his practice would have happened
after he got into the new world
yeah and i guess he started when he
wasn't i guess i don't think he was
wanted was he he wasn't wanted pophill
didn't put any charges on him
nope so he could just go to the united
states under his own name he was free
there
yeah he ordered wherever he went and he
already had his education so he didn't
need to go to school or anything
yeah because he already had medical uh
yeah he did maybe he did some extra [ __ ]
for psychology but that's you know
and i mean like i said when the movie
ends he's still pretty young yeah still
yeah i mean he's like
yeah he's like in his early 20s he's
supposed to be so yeah he could totally
just be like yeah i'd want all these
like fancy medical schools yeah in
france and it's like you could just kind
of parlay it from there and then he
could just start killing people for
as long as he wanted to well even in
even in the movies the people he killed
were the ones that he thought needed to
die because they were rude they were
rude yeah either to him or to somebody
else
yeah and that's why that's starling's
boss he killed starling's boss because
she was a [ __ ] to starling
yeah because he was that [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] he ate he ate his brain
yeah and then he made that dude to eat
his own brand yeah
which is a pretty hardcore [ __ ] well
like i said i think that maybe that's
why a lot of people like resonated with
uh
hannibal lecter because yeah he's a
serial killer but he's kind of killing
some [ __ ] it's just the same kind of
thing as dexter it's like you're killing
like shitty people
no one's gonna feel all that bad you
know like him killing these be a [ __ ]
people remember the guy that
remember the guy that uh watched him was
also a medical student at the sanitarium
what was his name not harvey um
the black dude yeah yeah i know you're
talking about barney barney barney yeah
barney was in several of the movies and
barney said he liked
hannah he liked dr lecter and they
talked to dr lecter all the time and
that you know once you got to know him
and you kind of understand remember that
he said you kind of have to understand
that there's a certain way you have to
have to talk to it
you know and that you you'd be okay you
know he didn't he didn't you know barney
said that electric
elector wouldn't come after well even uh
you know it would be rude
no well silence of the lambs clarice
says that like after
uh dr lecter escapes and her friend is
all freaking out like you know and she
said he won't come after me
and then she said it's hard to explain
but he would consider that rude
yeah yeah because he liked her so he
wasn't gonna kill her
you know what i mean he only killed
people that he thought had in coming
yeah
he called him with the free range rude
yeah
rude people just running around their
food
the food like a free raising like i said
in some cases i can kind of endorse that
i gotta say so i don't feel all that bad
about him killing some of this been
going on since the dawn of [ __ ] man
anyway
our pre-human ancestors the tribal
warfare they were eating each other
yeah you didn't let meat go to waste and
plus you know even in native americans a
lot of tribal even
the mexicans and the mesoamericans down
in uh uh teotihuacan and [ __ ] like that
you know they ate those sacrifices
and you know it makes sense you're
trying to gain their strength and you're
gaining sustenance from
somebody who's kind of semi-willingly
given their lives through
ritual acts or it's a gift
from a relative who's died because you
know bush meat
you know yeah it's not all that weird
when you look at it from that uh
vikings did it you know they were
calling it long pig
you just didn't it's protein and you
just didn't let that [ __ ] go to waste
now in certain certain cultures it was
also kind of a way of
absorbing an enemy's strength but also
kind of desecrating him because of
course you ate him and then you [ __ ] him
out
yeah you know that you just kind of
reduced the person
just like the ultimate [ __ ] you yeah it
depends on how you
depends on how you interpret this stuff
um
is it civilized no not really by today's
standards but there were civilizations
that did it
yeah mexico was big into it you know the
conquistadors and ships said no they
openly sold human meat
yeah i liked in this one that basically
he didn't
he just ate the cheeks yeah he was
building up to it though
towards the end he was eating them raw
yeah
well especially that last guy because
actually that dude was just like the
worst
yeah so he's safe well he's like and
also you realize that he
he new aspects of what had actually
happened out there and
[ __ ] out there in the snow with misha
and everything yeah
and made him like super mad yeah yeah
it's like i'm not even i'm not even
gonna i'm not even gonna cook your face
i'm just gonna eat it yeah
after he carved like some [ __ ] in his
chest and everything yeah it's kind of
it's
kind of gory movie we should probably
watch the series hannibal
i've only seen a couple of the episodes
those seem to be okay
yeah i wonder because i know a lot of
people like really really dug it and i
was like i
i keep meaning to watch and i just
haven't got around to it i wonder how it
kind of like
dovetails in with this because i heard
there was some um
uh inconsistencies between the just the
backstory i guess but like i'm not one
of these people that you know in a story
like this that you have to have a
hundred percent consistency that you
know what i mean
yeah it's cool i didn't like it when
they varied when they [ __ ] up
star wars lore you know because they
already had all these books and all this
other [ __ ]
but something kind of like lector's
story i i think it's okay to
to take a little bit of license with it
it doesn't have a
a huge [ __ ] fandom of rabid fans
collecting all kinds of crazy [ __ ] it's
just a
a pretty cool story and you could retell
it a little bit long as it was within
within certain and if somebody
complained you could just make the
argument too it's like oh
we're just hearing things from lecture's
point of view and maybe he's lying or
maybe he's like exaggerating
or maybe someone else is telling the
story and they're lying exaggerating
you know what i mean so something like
that but yeah so uh
whis i think this is on hulu at the
moment i think it's on hulu or hamson
prime i can't remember
so if you have hulu you can watch it we
actually have the blu-ray so we watched
it
it's great on blu-ray got a lot of
extras it does yeah
yeah um you know obviously not my
favorite of the hannibal movies that
would be science and lambs uh
but you know it's i feel like it got
kind of bad reviews it didn't make a
huge amount of money it made more than
its budget but it didn't make twice so i
guess it was a little bit of a financial
disappointment
but uh that said i think it's actually
like a better movie than it's given
credit for i think technically and just
because of the the sets and the the
clothes the costumes even like the t-34
tag that they showed and little details
about the tank
it had a lot of accuracy with it and the
tone
i almost say i think i like it better
than silence the lambs even though
science of lambs is also a masterpiece
visually i like this one better well the
cinematography on this one's really
really nice i mean they really did kind
of go i mean just
visually this is like a beautiful
beautiful looking yeah it's just a good
looking movie
if you like if you like hannibal lecter
or you like science or lamps and you
like batman begins and you like
vampire movies like dracula you'd love
this
because it's kind of kind of combining
all that yeah it is kind of like
throwing it all in there together and
samurai [ __ ]
and samurai stuff yeah but yeah so you
know it's over on holy right now
so go check it out if you haven't seen
it let us know what you think about it
in the comments
and we will see you guys on the next one
bye
you